alright guys we got one more for you you
know how much i love jen sake
who is the white house press secretary
she doesn't like fox news very much and
she's watching them all the time to make
sure they're not doing bad stuff because
that's what the press secretary should
be doing or something like that here's
some video if you look at fox on a daily
basis i mean do you remember the four
boxes that you had that we had on all
the tvs right which is on my tv right
now so right now just to give you a
sense so cnn pentagon as many as 8 500
u.s troops on heightened alert okay true
same on msnbc cnbc is doing their own
thing about the market and then on fox
is janine pirro talking about soft on
crime consequences i mean what
what does that even mean right um so
there's an alternate universe on some
uh coverage what's scary about it is a
lot of people watch that
the smug
dismissive way that she has so
perfected
people upset that crime is running
rampant in cities
that's what those
fools
are covering over on fox news they're
not covering the stuff we want them to
cover as if you are the ones who get to
decide what they show
on news networks you're not because you
don't run the whole damn place and we're
not going to let you run the whole damn
place you get it sake i also realized
right before we threw to that clip when
i say sake sake where it comes from do
you remember true blood on hbo the
vampire show remember bill the vampire
he was always talking to sookie and he
would say sucky like that and that's
that i think that's where i'm saying
sake it comes from bill the vampire on
true blood there's some information for
you anyway i don't like this sake woman
i think news networks are allowed to
cover whatever they want but what she
really means there is oh fox is covering
our failures our meaning the democratic
party because it's the democrats that
run all of the cities that have been
soft on crime that are all crumbling and
when i did another bit on the show last
night with jordan about how many people
have moved here and it's like yeah
everyone's applauding because they're
fleeing the democrat run cities well
sake got called out on this very issue
at the white house press briefing
yesterday we are seeing crime surge in
major cities
and the president's poll numbers on the
topic you know there was a
he had an approval rating on crime was
at 36 and one december poll
does that indicate to the white house at
all that americans feel democrats are
out of touch when it comes to safety or
criminal justice and you know what's the
administration's takeaway to
these numbers and the rising crime
i think we all agree or should agree
that violent crime is a serious problem
we actually saw a record jump in murders
in 2020 under the former president and
there hasn't been new fbi nationwide
data that has been released to date
there has been city some city data of
course which is important to focus on uh
and talk about
our view is that instead of turning this
into a political football we need to be
focused from the beginning of
the president's time
all of his time in office on reducing
crime and keeping our community safe and
that's why he's been a long time
advocate for more accountable community
policing that's why he has uh supported
and advocated for additional funding for
proven community programs to reduce
prime why he's working to crack down on
rogue gun dealers who sell firearms to
criminals and why he's taken executive
action to crack down on ghost guns so
his objective is to work with democrats
republicans mayors local leaders to work
to address what we've seen as increases
in crime in some areas but i would just
note that nationwide there has been
increases in crime over the past few
years
must i even comment must i even comment
it's just meaningless nonsense that
she's saying you all know the truth
do you live in the city what's new york
city like do you live in san francisco
or los angeles now she's sort of
addressing i'll try to give the devil is
due here she kind of acknowledged
there's some problems in some cities
but might i remind you that chicago has
the strictest gun laws in the city and
michael we haven't done it for a while
how many people were killed in chicago
by guns this week connor do we have the
gun music we have to get that we don't
have it today we're going to get that
chicago that old-fashioned chicago gun
music when we put the numbers up for you
chicago has the strictest gun laws in
the nation and more people are killed in
chicago every single weekend killed and
shot in chicago every single week and
you can give me yeah okay you give me
last weekend if you want so first off
797 people were slain in chicago in 2021
okay that's number one give me last
week's gun numbers i think we can get it
i'm sure we can
now the reason that the media doesn't
cover it because they don't like who's
doing the shooting and in this case it's
usually black men shooting other black
men that doesn't fit the grand narrative
so they can't they can't show you that
but the
bigger point here is that everything
that that sake believes
is that is based around that the
government is supposed to do
uh something about all of this and that
if the government only had more power if
we had more laws if they had more money
if they could take more of your guns
that things would be better chicago is
the perfect example of why that doesn't
work and you all know it doesn't and
actually i mean i can't believe i'm
going to say this this is somewhat good
news only two people were shot dead in
chicago this weekend 22 were wounded by
bullets but they didn't die so that's
pretty good you know you'll take what
you can get chicago